mhmm, all diese Autos, zwei Specials
, die dort passieren, d, Mukesh, Katz-und-Maus-
Phillies, in dem Raum, mit ihnen selbst aufs
Feld, John Lasseter, Demokraten, waren
von Autos zu natürlich, Jamieson, Spielzeugautos,
Spielzeuggeschichte über schlaue beide Obertöne eines
Jagdkochs auf Pizza und a  Dings setzen auf
die Outs Phillies Interview Zugangscodes
als Gitarrenmelodie bestätigt
Adebayor dort oz töricht punto de buena
dicen Abstimmung über Alice kosmisch uns
etwas zu tun klickt auch nach Hause, noch ein
Ballenzeh der Knopf gehörte einem Johnston ja
Interview im Berg animierte
Nachfüllung  habe ich habe nicht die leine auf
vez a la familia Suzanne film chops sind
auch run line hallo john lasseter meine erste
frage ist wie läuft
alles super ich liebe autos auch
es hat so viel spaß gemacht an autos zu arbeiten
weil ich ich habe  Ich habe zwei Jobs und den
Chief Creative Officer von Pixar und
Disney Animation, aber ich kann auch
Regie führen, also hat es so viel Spaß gemacht, auch
für Autos auf den Regiestuhl zurückzukehren,
und ich sehe  Ich kenne die Welt der Autos,
und es hat so viel Spaß gemacht, diesen ganz
neuen Film zu machen. Es ist eine ganz neue Art von
Film für Pixar, es ist ein Spionagefilm und voller
Action, und es war eine tolle Zeit, einen
interessanten Film zu machen, den wir sehr mögen
Interessante Tabelle Ja, das sind die Autos
zum Hawaiihemd Ich trage Hawaiihemden
jeden Tag zu einem anderen Preis Meine Frau Meine
Frau Nancy sagt immer, Sie sollten
das Thema Ihres Hemdes an das anpassen, was
Sie tagsüber tun, also habe ich es in meinem Schrank
Meine Hawaiihemden sind alle
nach Thema sortiert, wie viele leichte in meinem
Schrank, die wir kürzlich gezählt haben, und ich nenne
diese Hemden und aktive Rotation. Okay, ich
375 Hemden, es war 374, aber ich habe dieses
in 375 so bekommen, und dann habe ich wahrscheinlich
leicht tausend schwere  oft aufbewahrung
okay denk nach, was war das für pläne, dass du
als regisseur zurückkehrst ja ich
wollte schon immer ich denke es ist wirklich wichtig
für mich als chef der kreativen abteilung
als führungskraft immer immer in der lage zu sein regieren zu können
aber du weißt, es ist ein paar jahre her
zwischen ich bin vorbei  Ich sehe all die anderen
Regisseure und
all die anderen Projekte, die
sowohl bei Disney als auch bei Pixar laufen, und ich liebe diesen
Teil meiner Arbeit, und ich kann auch beim
Entwerfen von Fahrgeschäften und Attraktionen für Themenparks helfen,
und wir haben so viel Spaß
dabei  Studios, die diese fantastischen
Filme erschaffen, und das Wichtigste ist,
dass sie unsere Filme großartig machen, aber ich
liebe es auch, Regie zu führen, denn wenn ich als
Chief Creative Officer, Executive
Producer an den anderen Filmen arbeite, arbeite ich
mit der kreativen Leitung jedes
Films zusammen  Ich gehe als Regisseur und arbeite
als Regisseur. Ich kann mit allen
Künstlern arbeiten und es ist wirklich wichtig für mich
, mit allen Künstlern in Kontakt zu bleiben, also
was ist deine Aufgabe, die du jetzt machst, also
gibt es so viele verschiedene Dinge, ja, ich
habe  Ich habe ungefähr fünf Vollzeitjobs und
das ist eine der Herausforderungen,
all das gut zu balancieren. Ich habe auch die
Regie bei Autos abgeschlossen, und wir machen gerade, dass
ich der Regisseur bin, der hier sitzt und
über meinen Film in ihnen spricht, und ich
will alle  zu  sehen Sie es sich an, weil Sie es
lieben, es ist ein fantastischer Film. Wenn
ich zu Pixar zurückkomme, werde ich der Chief
Creative Officer sein, der unseren kommenden
Film
beaufsichtigt  am College kennengelernt,
heißt Monsters Universe,
sehr lustig bei Disney, wir haben einen
fantastischen Film
namens Wreck-it Ralph, der komplett in der Welt der Videospiele spielt,
und das ist eine wirklich frische, originelle Idee,
und wir haben noch eine ganze Reihe weiterer Filme
, die wir haben.  Es wurde nicht wirklich angekündigt, weil
es vier Jahre dauert, einen unserer Filme zu machen.
Was sagt Ihre Familie
zu all dieser Arbeit? Ihre Frau und Ihre fünf sagen es
ihnen, wenn ich nach Hause gehe. Ich bin zu Hause. Ich
lasse meine Arbeit  etwa
eine Stunde pendeln zu mir nach Hause. Ich habe großes
Glück, denn ich lebe in Nordkalifornien,
lebe nicht in Hollywood, und ich kann
oben im kalifornischen
Weinland in Sonoma leben, und es ist so schön
und es ist ein bisschen wie Amerikas
Toskana oder  Amerikas Profi  Wenn Sie wissen
, dass es dieses Gefühl ist und es eine großartige
Lebensweise ist und es ungefähr eine Stunde
Fahrt dauert und ich auf meinem iPad arbeite, wissen Sie,
dass ich eine spezielle iPad-App für mich geschrieben habe,
damit ich die
Arbeit auf meiner Heimfahrt überprüfen kann  natürlich nicht
trocken okay ich bekomme ich fahre nach hause und dann
weißt du es ja aber wenn ich zu hause bin bin ich zu hause
also okay vielen dank ja super
danke danke dir